hey everyone it's sarah with
registerednessrn.com and in this video
i'm going to show how to prime a saline
flush and how to prime your extension
set whenever you're starting a
peripheral iv
before performing any nursing skills you
want to make sure that you're following
your hospital's protocols
to ensure you're following the latest
guidelines so why do we go through this
priming process whenever we are starting
an iv
well the saline flush is pre-filled with
saline
and it has an air bubble inside of the
syringe that we must remove because
we don't want to inject that in the
patient also
our extension set inside this tubing
there's nothing but
air so we want to make sure that we fill
it with saline so whenever we actually
inject into the patient the saline will
go in the patient
rather than the air and the reason we do
this and we don't want air to enter into
this venous system is because we don't
want to cause an air
embolism and there's different types of
air embolisms
so with a venous air embolism what could
happen is that
air could get into the venous system the
vessel
and it could block it it could travel to
the heart or the brain and cause serious
complications
so first what you want to do is you want
to perform hand hygiene
and then you can open up your packaging
so here i've already opened up
everything
and the first thing that i like to do is
i like to
undo this little cap that's on the
extension tubing because whenever you're
starting an iv you only have one hand to
really
work with and connect with and i like
this little cap right here
at the end to be loose because it's
really on there so i just loosen it up
and then just
slide it on there and then what i like
to do is i like to get my saline flush
and i'm going to prime it by removing
its air bubble so what you want to do
first is you want to take that cap
off and then slightly pull back
on the plunger and then
you can just flick it a little bit if
you want to get any air
bubbles that may be down in this area to
move up and you're going to
push the plunger up to expel that air
and wait for some saline to drip out
again you can flick a little bit more if
you have to and then just push
until all that air is removed
then what i'm going to do is i'm going
to take this flush
and i'm going to twist it on to my cap
of my extension tubing
so take it here twist it on
then i'm going to inject
the saline into the tubing and how i
know that all the air is cleared out i'm
going to watch it go through and then
i'm going to watch it drip
out into the packaging
and as you can see it's filtering
through and you can see
we have enough so i'm just going to
leave that
there and it is ready to go for whenever
i'm ready to start the iv
okay so that is how you prime the
extension tubing before you actually
start an iv
now if you would like to watch a video
on how to actually insert an iv
you can access the link in the youtube
description below